What sequence did you come up with,
David?
>> So from this state, there's seven
possible moves we can make initially.
Some of them are going to move
us away from our goal state.
So putting D on A or D on B are going
to move us away from our goal state.
To means and to analysis, the rest of
the moves are relatively the same.
Putting A on B doesn't get us closer,
putting B on C doesn't get us closer,
and putting B on D
doesn't get us closer.
However, we can see that we really
need to get B out of the way of C
to move it up here.
Like Ashad mentioned, later on we'll
talk about how an agent would decide
that it needs to get B
out of the way of C.
But for right now, let's just go ahead
and choose B on Table as the next move.
Given that, we now see that
of the next possible states,
only one reduces our difference,
and that's to put C up on D.
>> That was the right answer, David.
Thank you.
You will note that we're leaving
several questions unanswered for now,
and that is fine.
But you will also note
that this round reduction
helps us make progress
towards solving the problem.